Ferguson Missouri which of course you
guys all know about at this point we
haven't covered on the show yet so I
wanted to just sort of do a general
overview of what's been going on of
course eighteen-year-old Mike Brown was
shot by police officer Darren Wilson
about ten days ago looks like six
gunshots facing the officer so he was
not running away actually facing the
officer we've just got a little
breakdown of the timeline so let's take
a look at that okay so on August ninth
Michael Brown 18 robbed a convenience
store and was shot to death by a police
officer Darren Wilson he was unarmed but
reportedly reached for the officer's gun
that seems to be up for debate at the
moment on August 10th the candlelight
vigil was held to honor Brown which
turned violent more than a dozen
businesses were vandalized and looted
more than 30 people were arrested and
two police officers suffered injuries
tensions rose between protesters and
police every night and a little bit more
Fauria on August sixteenth a state of
emergency was issued for the Ferguson
area and a curfew was imposed from
midnight to 5am the curfew was lifted
after it failed to thwart any violence
on August eighteenth so the curfew has
not been in effect for the last couple
days this has become a huge media circus
on top of the obviously awful situation
in the first place we've got a couple
images of the militarization of the
police which this seems to be beyond the
the death this seems to be the part that
has everybody up in arms so to speak so
these are these are just we got four
images for you I mean this really looks
like and you guys can chime in of course
this looks more like a military than a
police doesn't it and I think this this
photo and subsequent photos I kind of
spoke to why people thought that
tensions were growing because a large
number of the protests like ninety
percent of the protests were very
peaceful yeah but then some of these
peaceful people were met with guns in
their face and then that kind of just
it's a snowball effect and so yeah you
[ __ ] that this to me is the iconic
one a guy on what appears to be a tank
basically what's the McDonald's in the
back we're McDonald's in the background
that McDonald's actually got into the
whole story because that's where the
reporters got arrested
but I mean literally with a sniper rifle
aiming at people you have a lot of
weapons that are also going from
military operations that are being
passed over to police departments
because of budget cuts and so you are
seeing sort of an increased military
militarization of police officers yeah
because of the nature of the weapons
that are available to them yeah okay so
I want to get to the militarization
stuff after but let's just start with
what actually happened and from
everything I've been watching I find it
very hard to ascertain what the actual
truth is I don't know that we're ever
going to get to the truth you know now
they're saying that the officer has had
a broken eye socket because Mike might
have punched him how much do you think
we're ever gonna get to the truth let's
just start there I don't think we'll get
to the truth because the two people
involved one is no longer here and one
has been shrouded in secrecy like he
hasn't spoken up he's delivered messages
to friends who have been delivered
messages but it's gonna it's gonna be
one sided the story will always be one
sided and like you said you have a
broken eye socket but then there's
another report that he wasn't in the
hospital but for an hour or so and so
you just have conflicting reports that
everywhere you turn and that's another
reason why everyone's so angry because
in the very beginning there wasn't
transparency we they had no the people
of Ferguson had no information you know
his body was in the street for four
hours uncovered like these little things
that keep coming out is just angering
this town and so it's creating this
divisive pneus it's now a race issue
it's just so much for this small city
it's it's overwhelming so speaking of
lack of transparency that to me also is
the bigger part now we've got all the
media there but for the first couple
days there seemed to be like a media
blackout there was a no-fly zone because
somebody said they somebody shot at a
helicopter how much of this really is
just like a media circus at this point
beyond again the facts that we're trying
to get you yeah I think the lack of
transparency is one of the biggest
issues and not the main issue because
unfortunately these incidents where we
have the youth being shot by police
officers happen time and time again but
this particular case in the way that it
was handled I think has brought so much
controversy and brought all the rights
right they didn't even want to release
the officer's name
we don't even know is darren wilson for
a long time and they've got officers
policing the area now with no name tags
which i don't even know how that could
possibly be legal and we we still don't
have it we barely got information about
the autopsy to right we don't know if
these shots were fired at close range or
you know long range and that's really
going to impact the way we view this
case as well you know if we find out
that you know these shots were fired
long range then there's really no case
for this struggle that happened
supposedly between Darren Wilson and
Mike Brown right but we still don't have
that information and I think that's the
issue that we're getting a lag and all
the information and so much of it as
being hidden yeah now Vanessa according
to my paper here it says you are
african-american yes is that yes okay so
then obviously you represent all
african-american people because that's
what they do on telugu diaper on my
shoulders yes it's a heavy burden so
yeah as the representative your
community how much for the black
community in America right now how much
of this goes beyond this particular
incident and more to the bigger issue of
race relations and you know everyone
said we're post-racial with Obama and
all that kind of stuff and that that
phrase right there just angers the
community more but it does go much
further than just Mike Brown we've had
cases you know Trayvon Martin is still a
very sensitive topic you know Oscar
Grant and you know from vacillation you
know there's just so many there was just
another african-american shot in st.
Louis yesterday exactly and so we we're
in a period where we want to be united
as a nation and we want to be all it as
one and we want to look at this as
America's problem things that we all
need to solve but when you get to the
root of it it was a white officer and it
was an unarmed black man and so that
tension is still there and it's a
difficult dialogue but it's one that
needs to be discussed so that there is
healing that we can move forward and we
can't all come together because not
every white man hates a black man you
know it's not that and we can all sit
together and be diverse and have these
conversations and not have tension in
those conversations yeah um what do you
make about the people on the right that
always say well look what's going on in
Chicago because they always bring up
Chicago probably since we started this
10 people were shot chicago i mean it's
it's almost that bad
but they say well we keep ignoring
Chicago but then we focus on this what
do you think that um you know I think
that that's a tough question but I think
like I mentioned earlier we have cases
happening in Chicago and Illinois we
have them all over the country so I
don't think it's a Chicago issue I don't
think it's a you know Ferguson issue
it's a national issue so for me that's
almost like a distraction tactic they're
saying oh but what about Chicago that's
right your Cosmo until something happens
somewhere else and then suddenly they
start caring is that going all right
final thought on this so just the the
media angle of it is there an inherent
problem with the media that the media
constantly because they need people to
watch they have to keep ratcheting it up
tension all the time so you can already
see how the media gets involved in the
story Chris Hayes on MSNBC they spent
half the day talking about how someone
threw a rock at him someone did throw a
rock at him and then they spend a day
talking about you know apparently
someone Don Lemon heard someone say the
n-word so then the story becomes about
what Don Lemon hurt like how much is is
this just that the media just keeps this
thing going and yes we need to shed
light on it of course and we're talking
about right now so I say that with all
you know the great assault but you know
but it's one day it's one thing to tell
the full scope of the story and there's
another thing when you are trying to
create or manipulate the narrative and
that's what happens a lot of times you
know instead of focusing on the case and
what the facts are and what we're
learning they're focusing on the riots
and the Molotov cocktails and looping
for scenes over and over again to make
it look like that is what's all the only
thing that's happening and forgets them
and we need to really look at the fact
that they're being there are three
autopsies that are happening and the
first one we heard are just planet blue
living area preliminary reports and so
we are getting some information and if
we would just focus on the information
we're getting and what we still need to
get then we won't get shrouded in
distraction tactics as we have been yeah
final thought so media how do you decide
who to trust when it comes to this case
and I think it's really difficult to
decide who to trust but I think this
makes an excellent case for having
police officers wear body cameras and
having some more video footage
eyewitness testimony is awful we know it
doesn't work we have different accounts
eerie here's a perfect case for
advocating for body cameras
there you go all right so obviously
that's just a little wrap-up of what's
been going on there hope we gave you a
little insight into it and of course the
story is not going anywhere